let's go to something that
when i found out recently so i i've
known you've done a million things but
one of the things i wasn't aware of that
you had a role in
ample and i before you interrupt me by
minimizing your role in it
which is for minimizing functions yeah
minimizing functions right exactly
um i i can just say that the elegance
and abstraction power of
ample is incredible when
when i first came to it about 10 years
ago or so
uh can you describe what is the ample
language
sure so ample is a language for
mathematical programming
uh technical term uh think of it as
linear programming that is setting up
systems of linear equations that
are of some sort of system of
constraints
so that you have a bunch of things that
have to be less than this greater than
that or whatever and you're trying to
find a set
of values for some decision variables
that will maximize or minimize some
objective
function so it's a way of solving a
particular
kind of optimization problem a very
formal sort of optimization problem but
one that's exceptionally useful
and it specifies so there's objective
function constraints and variables that
become separate from the data it
operates on right
so the that kind of separation allows
you to
you know put on different hats one put
the hat of an optimization person and
then put
another hat of a data person and dance
back and forth and
and also separate the actual
solvers the optimization systems that do
the solving
then you can have other people come to
the table and then build their solvers
whether it's linear or non-linear
uh convex non-convex that kind of stuff
so of what is the
do you use maybe you can comment how you
got into that world and
what is the beautiful or interesting
idea to you from the world of
optimization
sure so i preface it by saying i'm
absolutely not an expert
on this and most of the uh important
work in ample comes from my two partners
in crime on that bob ferrer who
uh was a professor of in in the
industrial engineering and management
science
department at northwestern and my
colleague at bell labs dave gay who was
numerical analyst
and optimization person so the deal is
linear programming
preface this by saying let's stay with
linear programming yeah linear
programming is the simplest
example of this so linear programming is
taught in school is that you have a big
matrix which is always called a and you
say
ax is less than or equal to b so b is a
set of constraints
x is the decision variables and a as to
how the decision variables are combined
to set up the various constraints so a
is a matrix and
x and b are vectors and then there's an
objective function which is just the sum
of a bunch of x's and some coefficients
on them and yet that's the thing you
want to optimize
um the problem is that in the real world
that that matrix a is a very very very
intricate very large and very sparse
matrix where the various components of
the model
are distributed among the coefficients
in a way that is totally unobvious
to anybody and so
what you need is some way to express the
original model which you and i would
write you know we'd write
mathematics on the board and the sum of
this is greater than the sum of that
kind of thing
so um you need a language to write those
kinds of constraints
and bob forwar for a long time had been
interested in modeling languages
languages that made it possible to do
this there was a
modeling language around called gams the
general algebraic modeling system
but it looked very much like fortran it
was kind of clunky
and so bob spent a sabbatical year at
bell labs in 1984
and uh he and he was in the office
across from me
and uh it's always geography and
uh he and dave gay and i started talking
about this kind of
thing and um he wanted to design a
language
that would make it so that you could
take these algebraic specifications you
know summation signs over sets
and that you would write on the board
and convert them
into basically this a matrix
and then pass that off to a solver which
is an entirely separate thing
and so we uh talked about the design of
the language i don't remember any of the
details of this
now but it's kind of an obvious thing
you're just writing out mathematical
expressions in a fortran like or
sorry an algebraic but textual like
language
um and um i wrote the first version of
this ample program my first c
plus plus program and uh that's very the
c plus plus
yeah and so i did that fairly quickly we
wrote
it was you know 3 000 lines or something
so it wasn't very big but it
sort of showed the feasibility of it
that you could actually do something
that was easy for people to specify
models and convert it into something
that a solver could work with
at the same time as you say the model
and the data are separate things so one
model would then work with all kinds of
different data in the same way
lots of programs do the same thing but
with different data so one of the really
nice things is the
the specification of the models human um
just kind of like as you say is human
readable like i
literally remember on stuff i worked i i
would send it to colleagues that i'm
pretty sure never programmed in their
life
just just to uh understand what the
optimization problem is
i think uh how hard is it to convert
that you said you there's a first
prototype in c plus plus to convert that
into something that could actually be
used by the solver it's not too bad
because most of the solvers have some
mechanism that lets them
import a model in a form it might be as
simple as the matrix itself
in just some representation or if you're
doing things that are not
linear programming then there may be
some mechanism that lets you provide
things like functions
to be called or other constraints on the
model
so uh so all ample does is to generate
that kind of thing
and then solver deals with all the hard
work and then when the solver comes back
with
numbers ample converts those back into
your original form so you know how much
of each thing you should be buying or
making or shipping or whatever
so we did that in 84 and i
haven't had a lot to do with it since
except that we wrote a couple of
versions of a book on it which is one of
the greatest books ever written i love
that book
uh i don't know why it's an excellent
book bob four wrote most of it
and so it's really really well done he
must be a dynamite teacher
and type set in late tech no no no are
you kidding
i remember liking the typography so i
don't know we did it with d-rov
i don't even know what that is yeah
exactly you're too young
i think of t-roff as as a uh
a predecessor to the tech family of
things it's a formatter that was done at
bell labs in this
same period of the very early 70s uh
that
predates tech and things like that by
five to ten years well it was
nevertheless they just i'm going by
memories
it was i remember it being beautiful
yeah it was nice
you